[Música]
[Aplausos]
son las 6 30 de la mañana comienza la
ronda de patrullaje en la reserva de
louis agua
básicamente consiste en sobrevolar lo
isabá y detectar cualquier cosa
interesante grupos de elefantes cuántos
son dónde están y de vez en cuando
sobrevuelo los límites del parque para
asegurarme de que el ganado de las
comunidades vecinas no entra
rápidamente divisa un primer elefante
luego varias familias
tan pronto como veo algo interesante lo
anoto en mi teléfono con esta aplicación
de geolocalización esto nos permite ver
todas nuestras observaciones la
actividad humana está más concentrada
fuera de nuestras fronteras por ejemplo
la recolección de madera el carbón o los
hornos también muestra la ubicación de
los animales salvajes ya sea vivos o
muertos
una vez en tierra dios y los
guardabosques se dirigen hacia los
animales que vieron desde el avión
ahora mismo veo entre 13 y 15 elefantes
aquí algunos son muy pequeños tienen
menos de seis meses también hay
adolescentes de entre 2 y 3 años los
adolescentes son los que vemos allá y
son un poco más grandes
las rondas de patrullaje se realizan a
diario como resultado de esta vigilancia
ningún animal ha sido asesinado por los
cazadores furtivos desde 2017 en luisa
va pero los guardabosques deben
permanecer vigilantes no esperamos
necesariamente encontrarnos con
cazadores furtivos u otras personas pero
si tropezamos con la gente equivocada
allí estaremos para ocuparnos de ellos
en los últimos 30 años se han
adoptado iniciativas similares en toda
kenia como resultado la población de
elefantes se ha duplicado y asciende a
casi 35.000 los equipos y las
aplicaciones del gps que utilizan los
guardabosques son proporcionados por la
ong space for science espacio para
gigantes en español sus empleados
también rastrean a los animales para
protegerlos
cerca de los pueblos se puede seguir la
posición de los elefantes en tiempo real
este parece estar cerca a menos de un
kilómetro de donde estamos si se acercan
a las vallas nunca se sabe si tienen una
intención de destruirlas en ese caso les
advertimos a los guardabosques y les
pedimos que se mantengan alerta porque
hay un elefante muy cerca de la
comunidad de la granja que podría cruzar
el milan
y finalmente logra encontrar al animal
esta vez no hay peligro habrá que seguir
vigilándolo e intervenir si se acerca
demasiado a la valla construida por
espacio para gigantes actualmente el
mayor temor de las organizaciones de
protección ya no son los cazadores
furtivos sino los conflictos entre
humanos y animales en total 130
kilómetros de vallas permiten que haya
una buena convivencia con los
paquidermos dispersas estas vallas están
aquí desde 2018 el año en que terminamos
esta parte desde entonces no hemos
registrado ningún cruce de fans
especialmente donde están las granjas
antes era un cruce muy concurrido de
hotspots en las últimas cuatro décadas
la población de kenia se ha triplicado y
se ha extendido sobre el territorio de
los animales salvajes los agricultores
les temen especialmente a los elefantes
y a menudo reaccionan violentamente a
sus visitas hasta hace tres años los
elefantes solían venir aquí regularmente
para comerse la producción de maíz
los elefantes se han convertido en
nuestros amigos porque ya no vienen a
molestarnos antes los matábamos algunas
veces los considerábamos realmente como
enemigos porque venían a destruir todas
nuestras cosechas
pero ahora que están bien custodiados en
reservas con bayas nos gusta ver los
fans a barack en casas a túnel fría
taiwo para evacuar a toque a poco era un
millón a bisturí en toda kenia es
necesario proteger los cultivos y
explicarle a la población que aunque los
elefantes pueden causar daños en las
cosechas su presencia puede traer
ganancias
la reserva de luisao a desarrolló un
programa para ayudar a la población
local en este hotel los huéspedes pueden
dormir en una verdadera cámara bajo las
estrellas el concepto fue desarrollado
por el parque pero el establecimiento le
pertenece a la comunidad es una forma
alternativa de conseguir con que
sobrevivir aquí tenemos una vida nómada
pero con el tiempo tratamos de encontrar
nuevas alternativas esto es lo que
hacemos con la conservación construimos
este lugar para atraer a los turistas la
escuela del pueblo fue construida por la
red
al igual que el dispensario este grupo
de mujeres aprenden un oficio gracias a
los entrenamientos organizados por lo
isabá parte del dinero recaudado por la
reserva es sistemáticamente devuelto a
los habitantes una forma de mostrarles
la importancia de proteger a los
animales dijo vidic notando estando
antes no entendíamos por qué era
importante proteger a los animales pero
ahora gracias a estas formaciones hemos
aprendido mucho sobre la conservación
sobre los animales de salvajes sobre la
coexistencia entre los humanos y los
animales
ahora toda la comunidad estaba haciendo
lo posible para proteger lustral cuya
empresa inasa con mini t
todos estos esfuerzos están empezando a
dar sus frutos este año el país tuvo un
número excepcional de nacimientos y cada
vez menos elefantes mueren por la caza
furtiva hasta ahora 7 paquidermos han
sido asesinados en 2020 en comparación
con 34 en 2019 y 80 en 2018